cinéma avec la sortie mercredi prochain
de just married où l'on retrouve le
couple inoubliable de pretty woman julia
roberts et richard geere une comédie
sentimentale
nicole cornu longue dix ans plus tard un
nouveau rendez vous pour le couple
mythique de pretty woman loin du palace
de beverly hills
on les retrouve en province à baltimore
bien évidemment il ne s'agit pas du tout
la même histoire qui est du travail qui
m'attend
l'homme d'affaires le pygmalion qui
métamorphose est la fille des rues en
héroïne de conte de fées à coups de
cartes de crédit et le choeur est devenu
un journaliste signe misogyne fasciné
par les aventures d'une quinquagénaire
qui a rompu quatre mariages leur
relation difficile au départ s'améliore
peu à peu
vous êtes parfaite
je
vous lisez votre journal carrément à
l'envers c'est que je suis presque
parfait le schéma classique de ce genre
de comédie c'est je te hais je tuais des
finalement je t'aime vous ne pouvez pas
juste aimer ou juste haïr seymour
ennuyeux alors vous devez jouer l'ironie
et vous devez être honnête avec des
sentiments que vous exprimer
sinon ce n'est plus une comédie c'est un
drame
pour mieux la connaître il visionne ses
différentes tentatives de mariage avant
qu'elle ne prenne la fuite
l'essai de comprendre son comportement
pour mieux la piéger et tenter de
l'épouser
oui
ça tu présentes mais c'est drôle parce
que magee est comme un puzzle pour moi
je crois que la seule chose que nous
ayons en commun et que je puisse
comprendre injuste parce que le reste
est un mystère pour moi c'est son sens
de l'absurdité
si vous ne vous connaissez pas vous même
vous ne pouvez pas être vous même avec
votre si votre partenaire ne vous
comprends pas elle ne peut pas être
satisfaite mais aussi l'important pour
les deux on c'est de se sentir
responsable et l'avant le courage d'être
soi même c'est là la seule condition
d'une bonne relation et et s'il ya une
moralité dans ce film c'est celle-là des
péripéties piquante mais un dénouement
sans surprise qu importe le couple n'a
rien perdu de son charme
et pas de doute c'est drôle ça a été
relancée